as in trunk hitting back hard against
Democrats who say they want to take away
your guns 2020 candidate veto O'Rourke
leading the charge he's refusing to back
down after saying he'll confiscate guns
Trump tearing into bado and others last
night
left-wing Democrats want to confiscate
your guns and eliminate your god-given
right to self-defense as your president
I will never allow them to take away
your Liberty and I will never ever allow
them to take away your sacred right to
keep and bear arms and another 20 20
Democrats joining the calls for
mandatory gun buybacks here's Kamala
Harris a buyback program is a good idea
now we need to do it the right way
and part of that has to be you know
buyback and give people their value the
financial value of what they have and
not just take things from people that
have value without compensating them all
right so one for many many years
Republicans have said Democrats are
coming for your guns and you guys would
say oh no that's not true that's just a
right wing talking point but now we know
it's true because they are coming for
our guns Nona so what is it like to be
wrong for you it's true he said assault
I don't have much how many times play
any tape you want he says we're coming
for excuse me weapons have belong on a
battlefield intended to kill and maim
that's what he that's every gun ever
made they carry handguns except for BB
gun yeah but you didn't say handguns he
said assault weapons okay so Chicago
gangs are safe America the American
public wants politicians to do something
but there's a disconnect with the
politicians at this moment because the
politicians are all trapped by the NRA
money and media and threats so look
here's what here's my thought today jest
okay Obama couldn't do anything about
this even after Newtown mm-hmm you know
Bush couldn't do anything about it I
think Trump has a unique opportunity
he's position in terms of his populist
appeal and all that and the fact that
he's close to the NRA to actually get
something done he says that he's
gonna pick up on the house the
Democratic house-passed bill that
requires universal background checks but
mr. Trump if you would do that I wan
Williams he's saying they were praised
leave before until reelected oh really
but I think you know what it's like what
do you did on criminal justice reform
Gregg yes those other presidents didn't
get it done I think this guy could do so
I've been saying that forever so what
are the bipartisan ideas on reducing
mass shootings that the president could
possibly move forward on well I you know
I've talked about the civil tag system
which unfortunately bado has totally
effed up by put making it about him so
he's now saying like what he sees
somebody doesn't like he's gonna call
the FBI and say you can't have a gun
that feeds into the scare that the fears
of people who own guns that civil tag or
a red flag system will be used unfairly
I was hoping that wouldn't be the case
that you go to a courts yeah people who
are who are you know health workers or
police officers or school principals
that are there to talk about the
students now what Beto's done has made
it sound like I could just make a phone
call and you'd lose your guns so he
would you know to get the spotlight for
himself he really screwed up a lot of
progress I also think that there think
that there's there is progress to be
made in cosmetic thing and cosmetic
things that you put onto guns that
aren't necessary that tend to attract a
certain kind of gun owner people
disagree with me on that but that's okay
we can discuss it answer Jesse's
question I just did seriously you I did
seriously I think it's like 80 or 90
percent say background checks are cool
eighty or ninety percent say red flags
are cool right people I think it's even
most Republicans and most NRA members
say all these big magazines with
high-capacity we don't need would you
agree with that no I just said oh my god
I just talked about the civil taxes of
what I've been talking about for two
years it's like stuff yes and I also
talked about recently I talked about the
whole idea of the cosmetic additions to
guns that don't change the power of the
gun that maybe attract a certain kind of
use yeah because the ar-15 I mean you
really can't hunt with that because you
can barely put down anything
I mean it's not really that powerful of
a gun but they make much more powerful
rifles that can really hurt people that
the Democrats don't even talk about it's
just the AR because of the stylizations
to make it look militaristic do you
think that the White House is trying to
figure out a way what could they propose
that would be able to get some
bipartisan support it is a tricky thing
I do think however you know if you read
the story today that the NRA that
there's concern on Republicans in
Republican circles that the NRA won't be
as powerful in terms of get out the vote
because of the troubles that they're
having but the thing is is that better
or work and Kamala Harris for example
are doing that work for them like that
yeah it's already going to energize
people to come out to vote so I do
and then the president he might be able
to find something to do on background
checks but the devil will definitely be
in the details what do you think about
the high-capacity magazines you know you
have ten in a usual weapon maybe thirty
and a rifle you limited at sixty the
eliminated a hundred or is that
something you think that people can get
behind well that's interesting maybe I
think that might be a regulation that
the more of a plurality might go for
rather than mandatory confiscation if I
can focus on calmly Harris though for a
second you know for someone who has had
decades of criminal justice experience I
find her oversimplification and also
flip-flopping exhausting and really
confusing and she started with the
take-back and then now the buyback which
makes no sense because the government
didn't sell it to begin with but you
know she she builds herself out as a
quote progressive prosecutor but when
she was California's AG it was status
quo and under her reign there were a lot
of frankly atrocities that happened that
now she has distanced herself from right
the Supreme Court said you're
overcrowding in California is literally
cruel and unusual prison labor all of
these things and she came out and
defended it by saying well I wasn't
behind the offices messaging I literally
had no idea
I find that either inadequate or
incompetent and so for me coming from
California and with also a criminal
justice background that's why I wanted
to take this moment to highlight her
jump in on this bandwagon
which i think is ineffective and I don't
think it's energizing a base I think
it's it's simply rhetoric that people
who take it one step further
think about the policy realizes totally
ineffective and by the way Kabul is now
losing in California - Andrew yang